Daniel do you weigh in on what you said
a little while ago things that are
experimental things that carry a lot of
risk that they actually will not
immediately if ever have a have a
benefit you know in business school
that's really easy because one of the
assumptions that has made a business
school as most businesses fail and so
the outliers are the one that we hear
about because they survived and
philanthropy it's so hard to tell donors
well you know most things fail and but
still invest how do you balance and how
do you talk to donors about the
potential failure of their investment
okay to me I actually asked more
questions than tale donor I find I learn
more that way I think there's a
difference between doing something that
other people have done and there are
results and blindly going in and
ignoring history and precedent versus
experimenting in a new area that really
hasn't been as well researched so the
questions that I'll ask for donors who
are going into areas that look more
based on emotion that outcomes what's
the competitive landscape what's
happened there before why are you trying
this approach as opposed to the other
ones and I find that the portfolio
theory of tried and true well researched
experimentation and the blend in between